welcome to this video playing placebo
not placebo but almost all right so if
I've let's play life like I usually do
and tournament chess the room was pretty
high rated but I never played played
this account I it's a brand new account
just a couple of games but very high
ratings in all three categories okay so
very often this kind of nameless
accounts are secondary accounts of
strong title players um if you have a
title which is higher than feeder master
feeder masters does not help but I am
wim wgm GMS on you get one free account
on is here under which you need to have
your name listed so you need to put it
in who you actually are and you also
entitled them a second account if you
want to play em and not none and
nonnamous lee screwing this up
anonymously um and this is may be such
an anonymous account okay um he played
the line with 94 this one the so-called
gates variation I have some experience
with this opening in and blitz and
tournament chess but still I don't feel
like I I know the finer points yeah this
for instance is curious if I just take
it what is the point Queen takes and I
take one D for winning upon you might
get it back
hmm okay but still I mean he's very
likely getting it back but in the
meantime I will get some some good piece
play going i hope with 97 bishop f6 or
something along these lines the night
years so it's not a bad piece at term is
active and it's not easy to ya to be
expelled I mean be three years easy move
to play but it weakens the long diagonal
so often 97 Bishop f6 is stronger than
he's taking lots of time early
somewhat strange
really two minutes two and a half
minutes for this position yeah it's not
like I'm laughing at him it sir just er
it's just a weird for a strong player
because it's a very yeah it's a no no
respectable opening and you always have
this kind of yeah underlying suspicion
that there might be something fishy
going on so let's let's see i can t
three hour d3 is a very solid way to
play at rook c8 why not I'm just nicely
developed here and I have a pawn okay
taking this still I can return to with
d3
yeah I have many ways to equalize like
d5 here or d3 but I don't feel like
there should be more somehow but i don't
i don't see it ready don't see it okay
let's do that i think this should be it
should be quite okay this was my idea
now we're taking here brah our third now
no I actually think I'm quite ok here I
know it's got the higher rating and
since and such but i think i'm a bit
better developed here with bishop f6
coming especially now after the Queen
trade this is the funny case that this
night the song was dominating the bishop
the bishop does not have a good square
and I have Bishop f6 coming in addition
a very typical position in the room um
if everything's running a nicely for
black of course it's not like you get
this every time Bishop a5 p.m. that's a
good move yeah that's a good move okay
so maybe hmm Bishop here Bishop f5 yeah
moving the rook would almost be a self
pin and looks really strange now maybe
it's still good
just rope here I don't see how he uses
the the pin that's why that's how it's
not difficult just ripped it to go ah ok
that was bad really bad play what I did
them Wow okay my back rank is Sam is
weak and I need to play a move like h5
really badly of Bishop f6 is also a
booth let's make sure that i'm not
getting mated here no i don't not sure
time warning yeah yeah okay check that's
some way to okay let's just get the King
King into the game that's necessary
anyway night c 5 i'd like to I like to
prevent let you find maybe but it does
not really help him don't want to
exchange ready it's a bit more active
there should be two as a threat yeah
that suits long Zuka smile I'm entering
with the King now or this one Kings he
took inform mr. point the I a
threatening a five now important check
white resigns yeah it should have ended
in a draw of course but when I when I
declined it around here every thought
I'm slightly better I'm not quite sure
where he offered it to be honest but
here it is it looks like some activity
but maybe it's just it's just
evaporating with with a good play yeah
down probably it is I don't know yeah
that's this this is very important he
needs to have this resource other than
that I play Bishop f6 and oops nope not
there to shoot to f6 mmm to put this
pressure and this yeah this is very
obvious now I needed to really break the
spin quickly to to get an equal position
yeah and I think we were it was fairly
equal for quite a long time check
yeah yeah this is just dead but he made
some strange decisions it's not
necessary to put it on dark square cm
it's I'm not sure how how terrible it is
but it's not not necessary to do and
here i will ya can that stupid i can
just take your course and and run this
is quicker for black if you look at this
something like him this is just far far
too slow yeah that's that's really easy
but i was thinking about this should be
too of course and and here yeah it's
already a bit tricky it cannot really
move the King as I'm invading we should
move Bishop b2 I don't know the computer
wants to play Bishop g5 it obviously
thinks that this calculates this year
okay I understand so that's probably
drawing right it's very hard to to get
anything going Bishop see 785 yeah yeah
I don't get him into soup song here he's
super savant he was a maybe here maybe
this one yeah this is this is what this
is still a draw well this is losing okay
we weren't very little time so but check
let's understandable that mistakes are
happening yeah it probably should should
have ended in a draw right here was
where I declared the draw
right yeah I think you can do that it's
not it's not unfair or anything alright
thanks for watching